[موسيقى]
السعفه الذهبيه لمهرجان كان السينمائي
ذهبت هذا العام للفيلم الفرنسي تشريح سقوط
وتدور احداثه حول محاكمه امراه متهمه بقتل
زوجها وكيف تحاول تبرئه نفسها وتعتبر
مخرجه الفيلم جوستين تريي ثالث امراه في
تاريخ المهرجان تفوز بسعفته التي تعتبر
الاهم في عالم السينما
كان انت
المخرج البريطاني جونيزر حصل على الجائزه
الكبرى للمهرجان عن فيلمه ديزون اوف
انترست الذي يروي فيه الحياه اليوميه
لعائله قائد معسكر النازيل الاعتقال
والاباده حيث يقطن على مقربه من المعسكر
الفيلم صور القدره على التعايش بلا مبالاه
مع الموت والشر
جائزه الاخراج ذهبت للمخرج الفرنسي
الفيتنامي
عن فيلمه
وفاز بجائزه اللجنه التحكيم الفيلم
الفنلندي الاوراق المتساقطه للمخرج اكي
كورسماكي وقصتها عن رجل وامراه يلتقيان
صدفه لتتغير بعدها حياتهما
[موسيقى]
اما جائزه افضل ممثل فذهبت الممثل
الياباني كوجي يا كوشو عن دوره كعامل
تنظيفات في فيلم
للمخرج الالماني
[تصفيق]
وجائزه افضل ممثله كانت للممثله التركيه
ميرف ديزدار عن دورها في فيلم عن الاعشاب
الجافه للمخرج نوري بيلج جيلان
[موسيقى]
وحصل فيلم الياباني الوحش للمخرج كوري
ايدا هيروكازو على جائزه السيناريو التي
تسلمها الكاتب كوجي يا كوشو